of course found a Jillian Turner tells
us where things stand right now the Iran
deal is coming up
after months of will he won't he read
her it the nuclear deal is on the
president's mind once again this week as
he faces a May 12th deadline to decide
whether to recertify it now policymakers
are once again abuzz about the
agreements future and there's a growing
consensus that this time around it may
finally be dead once and for all leaders
on Capitol Hill predict the president
will pull out in coming weeks given that
the US Britain France and Germany have
so far failed to agree on a path forward
I think the president likely will move
away from it unless my our European
counterparts really come together on a
framework the US EU and Iran are
convening in Vienna this week for the
latest round of negotiations in the US
wants action on a list of complaints
including Tehran's ballistic missile
program alleged support for terrorism
illegal detention of American prisoners
egregious human rights record and cyber
and maritime aggression this as other US
allies from the Middle East are weighing
and loudly here in Washington do you
believe Iran is breaking the deal
currently I believe that the Iranians
are doing whatever they can to try to
move forward with regards to their
nuclear program administration officials
claims Secretary of State Tillerson had
been the deal staunchest advocate some
speculating it's why the president
decided to replace him but now with
Tillerson out and CIA director Mike
Pompeo slated to take his place
president Trump has solidified a foreign
policy team that backs terminating the
deal
director Pompey was made very negative
comments about the Iran deal and logic
Ben takes you to the point of saying
we're going to scrap the deal create a
new reality and find another way to
prevent Iran from getting deliverable
nuclear weapons advocates of the nuclear
deal argued that pulling out of it now
would anger European allies and risk
leaving the u.s. without any options
other than military confrontation or
even war but experts insisted even if
President Trump reneged on the deal
he remained open to diplomatic
engagement with Iran in the future